[Music]
harmonize with me
you're shining bright I'm your oyster
baby you're my Pearl
[Music]
Billy and Dom eat the world hello here
we are you join us here in the all
expenses spared uh stage for a billion
dumb eat the world and we will in fact
eat the world very slowly one mouthful
at a time now William yes this week it
looks like we're eating Ramen which is a
noodle snack from I don't know what what
Asian country Japan I would say Korea I
would say Japan well let's agree to
disagree okay
but we're not just eating Ramen no we're
eating Ramen with here we are momo fuku
chili crunch
as you can see here now what we are
gonna do yep is is supposed to be
relatively hot but we're like oh thank
you I'm gonna put a little bit of it I
would say for me I would say probably a
teaspoon with this a fork spoon yeah I
need it we need a spoon that's right
yeah we both like spicy food but John
almost Johnny clothes almost choked on
it earlier on yeah his heart blew off
I did blow off oh it looks good tell you
what it looks good now I'm gonna read a
little bit about Mama fuku it says here
ever since the early days of Mama fuku
they've been working on a chili oil that
has heat texture
Umami that crazy flavor that we all know
and a proper balance of flavor the
result the result is Momofuku chili
crunch the story of how they got there
is a journey that takes us from America
to China to Mexico with a quick stop in
Denmark now should we try it first why
are you stopping Denmark no I don't know
right okay here we go don
crunch
right Gundam
you've got a little bit on your face but
not too bad that
oh yeah
it is hot I hate the crunch I like the
crack I like the Heat
the sage of your tongue oh I'm gonna
have another bite oh my God this is
fantastic you like it
I'm gonna could you put some maybe I'll
just do it myself put on so I make sure
that I'm definitely that's what I'm
tasting oh that is a lot look at that
done treat yourself is that a good bite
should I do that
okay
yeah
um
all the crunch is good but the crunch is
fantastic
yeah I like it
around
oh
and just to be a hundred percent and
I've just licked this sorry about that
no time well I put the other end up you
and I basically family or whatever you
want not me no just of stuff I'm gonna
eat that so I know I'm definitely
getting the flavor okay
foreign now
umamu things are things like seaweed
and what else is umamu that's a
different way
um it's like a Maltese
um fermented flavor what do they say
that's the sex flavor or the
salt seaweed sour
better
Twisted Autumn and Sneezy yeah and umamu
but seaweed is an example of an umamu
taste what else is I think Marmite maybe
is umamu yeah I would think so don I
really like that I would describe that
as [ __ ] fantastic isn't it good not
great
chili flakes right
what kind of oil
I'd say
corn seed oil very coarse rapeseed oil
what rapeseed oil rape seed no no but
even coarser
then this is big him in an hour now it
begins with the G and you've got all the
rest of it
grape seed oil grape seed oil chilies
yes is there any nuts in there
I got a Nutty thing but no no no
seaweed you got seaweed seaweed
um okay various spices there's a sugar
in it but it's not a normal chicken
molasses healthy sugar no not carrying
sugar brown sugar it might fall off a
tree and kill you coconut sugar coconut
sugar garlic sesame seeds yes I should
have said so jellies mushroom powder
salt shallots spices yeast extracts oh
yeast extract very yummy that's a new
mommy flavor and I think mushrooms are a
new mommy flavor seaweed yeah
umamu mushrooms umamu yeast extract well
it's very um it's very tasty let's read
a little bit more about very very good
as a child Mo KU [ __ ] that's the um name
of the company moku fuku's Creator Dave
his favorite sources were the vinegary
oily Chinese chili sauces from
restaurants like Wu garden and eating
Gourmet in near his hometown in Virginia
later after moving to New York he began
eating a lot of I'm gonna hopefully get
this right Lao Gan ma very good chili
crisp the Chinese consonant uh condiment
sorry beloved by knowledgeable Cooks
around the world when momufuku our
product right here first began serving
roast docks at Samba chili crisp was one
of the OG condiments now I can imagine
that to be very good on something like
egg fried rice done
that's fantastic it's really good
because it doesn't overpower but it's
very Spacey and I love that crunch we've
almost eaten half the jar yes I tell you
what it's going to get high scores this
let's score it two stop taste and or
flavor I'm gonna drink the soup to get a
real taste of it all right I'll do that
and all then
I mean
no question it has improved this Ramen I
would say at least four times
better so we're already getting on your
usefulness but we'll get back to you
taste taste I'll let you uh recover I'm
I'm giving it a I'm gonna give it a 9.7
that is a fantastic tasting chili
crunchy I'm going to very quickly follow
you up there with a 9.5 brilliant
repeating I think it's more than noodles
now oh is it looked Aesthetics the jar
and the product itself the Jazz quite
small and dainty and sweet
I like it I like that I like the text
the font that they've used it's quite
playful isn't it
I'll zoom in but it won't be in Focus so
there's no point really it looks
roasting hot it's not quite as hot as it
looks eh yeah but you're very confident
shaking that aren't you I was nervous
but I've got a very very solid grip you
do yeah
um it does look nice I like that why is
it got what's that an orange a lemon
yeah it looks like a nose but they don't
have that in there does it no grape seed
is it the grape seed oil no it's not
grape Oh see it's leaking
I'm gonna have to demote a couple of
things there looks
um I I like to as soon as we get sent it
by that lovely person that sends it yes
thanks lovely person we'll include your
name in the show notes absolutely
um
don't worry it sometimes does it
bulletin John
because Billy's done don't worry there's
help coming what happened there you have
a mini stroke up the back of my nose my
God but that's a good thing right
there's water coming in
John oh John Justin James absolutely
saved us thank you John you were just
about to give it scores for looks looks
I'm going to give it an 8.2
I love it it looks like fire it looks
like everything that I like in food
spice crunchiness texture
umami
I'm gonna give it air
9.7 again it's high high scores no
usefulness and here's where it really
comes in here so undone that's perfect
because if that is sitting in my
whatever you've got to keep it louder
Pantry yeah not fridge it's all right
because of the oil preserving it so
that would sit next in my Jardin era
which we've done before and that thing
we go through two jars of that a week
that's fantastic so this thing would sit
next to it and it'd be just as if not
more useful I think yeah
recipes eggs on a piece of cheese and
noodle I mean that made like a cheap
thing of noodles tastes absolutely
fantastic
on your pizza maybe I've never
for usefulness I'm giving that a 10 my
first ever ten ladies and gentlemen what
a moment what a momentous moment here
well people will remember that yeah they
will I'm gonna give it because I I have
to say I probably still think Jordan Air
is a little bit more useful than that
and I can't remember what usefulness I
gave to Jordan now I'm giving it a nine
I love it I love normally that you think
of usefulness is can you take it on the
train can I put it in my pocket and
hours later offer it to Hungry people
it's a dull thing you could I'm a little
nervous mine's great high scores for
jelly crunch I wonder what Momofuku
means and I would guess that's Japanese
I would think Momofuku it's it's
absolutely wonderful get yourself some
of this yeah we are in uh no expenses
spared billion dominates the world's
stage
getting ready to eat a mysterious dish
this week William it's over to you
Dominic this one comes from Cora hello
from the south eastern US and uh Cora
says here in the South many people love
mayonnaise especially a brand called
Dukes we put me on everything but most
famously or perhaps infamously
on banana sandwiches
two pieces of white bread sliced bananas
and a generous dollop of meal I think
it's an
Abomination wow lovely ones yeah but I'd
like to see or hear what you both think
anyway thanks for the uh the podcast so
this came up last week again John when
we were eating um peanut butter and uh
pickle with uh neck vial and uh you
thought we were going to be doing this
because you've read this yeah so we
thought we'll do it this week yeah
because we'd already mentioned it and
you think it sounds awful right you I
watched you make your own sandwich and I
made man you slathered your bread with
mayonnaise covered I only put a little
bit of mayonnaise on mine nowhere near
as Brave all right should we have a bite
I'm not looking forward to this here we
go make sure you get banana and Mayo are
you ready let's do it okay
I mean I'm not even a massive banana
sandwich fan I like it with Nutella I
love banana so I'm just get it all over
your face
I made sure I got a lot of it
um
I hope banana sandwiches don't like that
really I mean I'm not gay ones I was
buying a car
there's a Nissan
and the guy I bought it from at the at
the place the Nissan place
had a banana sandwich every day of his
life
35 years well I mean banana is very good
for you full of potassiums you had sold
me the other day they're a natural
antidepressant is that right it is yeah
yeah so they're very good for you see a
lot of um
athletes specifically tennis players in
between their little break from one set
to the other or one game today very
quickly eating a banana because it's
great for energy and the more yellow it
is the more slow energy you get and the
more black it is Boom wow because the
Sugar's ready to go I'm not a massive
fan of bananas I love all fruit and I'm
okay with bananas but they're not at the
top of my list I would put them probably
down in in the in the lower 50s of my
through
you liking that I'm loving a dog I mean
you it's just still covered in
mayonnaise I would say
you look like the Joker a little bit you
know when the joke had his of his mouth
like you want to know how I got the
scars
I love another bite I'm not crazy about
it it's you've got the sugar from the
banana and the salt from the mayonnaise
the mayonnaise feels a little bit I
think because of the mayonnaise that
Johnny cloos has got us it tastes a bit
like one you'd have with a shrimp [ __ ]
too
I got a strange potato salad
it wasn't invented by Dale Earnhardt Jr
says Johnny Clues it wasn't no it turns
out that the banana and mayonnaise
sandwich is a southern delicacy with a
storied history in 2014
Nationals Bullpen coach Matthew Lacroix
maybe even credited credited it with the
team's 10-game winning streak what team
the team that he managed
nice one John I wonder what sport
baseball I would say the banana and
mayonnaise Summers gets at least enough
fans to have a Facebook page with 1 200
likes so there's 1 200 people I mean
you're halfway through it why doesn't
everybody watches this go on as a
Facebook page banana meals languages and
double it at least
yeah I mean Dom yeah I will link up
honestly you'd be surprised by how much
mail you got around your face wipe your
face now and see because you'll be
you'll be amazed there's a lot
okay that's quite greasy there's a lot
well you and I both like a banana
sandwich I've had banana sandwiches over
the years with uh chocolate hazelnut
spread which is fantastic that's a great
uh combination I've had banana
sandwiches with Jam yep I'm not too sure
about them I'm gonna have one more
you're almost halfway through I think I
like that I've only had a couple of
bites I'm not crazy about it
no
quite like it there's something about it
I quite like would you say that you like
that more than last week's uh peanut
butter and pickle yeah sandwich really
yeah I do so I need to remember the
scores I give now because yeah yeah if
I'd have bear scores they had won last
week yeah
let's score it so
um
taste
Dom I'm gonna give her a 9.4 wow you
genuinely do like it's not like a
gimmick no I actually really I would do
that again I'm confident in saying that
I probably would never eat that again by
choice wow
um I'm gonna give it a two I didn't like
it wow
how does it look to you dog well it's a
banana mayonnaise sandwich isn't it I
mean that looks revolting actually
yeah it doesn't look good when you open
up show that to the to the camera yeah I
see that now it's not it's not very
attractive
um
I'll give it a I'll give it a full for
looks Aesthetics
John uh yeah it doesn't look great but I
mean I'll give her a five okay no
usefulness usefulness if you were in the
Great Depression listen Beggars can't be
choosers and at that point obviously
everyone's struggling with a little bit
of money yeah calories we need calories
you need something to feed your kids
we're trying to make maps of this this
new country and and also things that
last you know mayonnaise you can put on
a on a cupboard and it'll stay good for
a while I would assume right
bananas don't now they go fast I hate
that yeah
not as fast as a fair
go first well at least with a banana you
see it yeah changing I need a couple of
days for that but a pair the night
before you think nah there's a few days
on that you wake up the next morning
done oh yeah you can eat every bit of up
here is that right you told me that I
think I'm not sure if that was me
actually no my brother used to I don't
know if he does it anymore but my
brother used to eat every bit of an
apple
that's not good because the seeds are
actually poisonous is that right yeah
tell them not to do that never put an
apple on a like one of those machines
not the whole Apple not the seeds could
see if you break the seed down that's
poison
is that right
anyway
um where are we at oh usefulness he's
gonna well I always think with something
like this can you bring it on a on a
journey on a car Journey on a trip you
go into this Cinema or something like
that on a road trip you could definitely
bring banana and mayonnaise somebody's
on a road trip there's no problem with
that huh
my usefulness is like if it's all I had
in the house what could it do with it is
it easy and you've normally got a banana
and you've normally got mayonnaise bread
so I might I can find it but is there
anything else I can do with it no no I
bet Elvis used to like these sandwiches
no no what did he like peanut butter
fried peanut butter and and jelly
sandwiches as they say oh you can't
travel with a certain place and get them
wouldn't it and I think sometimes he
would put a few slices of bacon in there
he liked his calories now so this died
on the toilet is that true though the
king died on the toilet
um
Dom I can only give that a four for
usefulness to be honest I think I'll
give it a 4-2 not a 42. a four a four we
are working with a snack called
dunkaroos Billy hey tell us about
dunkaroos well this was sent to us by
Caleb did you produce that Carl I think
Caleb Caleb sorry yeah so it's a
Biblical yeah it's a Biblical name Caleb
Whittington and air we don't have a
location I'm afraid but Caleb
Whittington he's a rolling stone and it
when a John Johnny Cruz saw this he says
we have to do this this is a big part of
my childhood and then when Amanda came
in today she said exactly the same thing
right this was never heard of them I've
never heard of me either supposedly this
was they were kind of big in the 90s
like us thank God yeah and uh now not
really about relevant like oh my gosh
made by Betty Crocker who are famous in
the United States for quite a lot of
baked goods and this they describe them
as a vanilla cookie and a chocolate with
a chocolate frosting
uh when's your best by day my Best Buy
day 15th of June 2022 17 minutes past
nine to the minute wow the minute
where's yours yeah mine's the same no
yours is 18 minutes past nine oh this is
one minute we should have these first
right there that's crazy that it's two
the minute yeah right open it I'll tell
you what it says on the thing first
vanilla cookies and chocolate Frost yeah
I just said that you don't listen to me
do you well well there's a dunkaroo song
here should we try and sing it in 1993
uh 1993 Don Cruz released a song during
one of its commercials that went let's
do it line for line okay like a zapper
go and I'll follow you go on my name is
Sydney I'm an awesome hunk an OP some
hunk I'll start again my name is Sydney
I'm an awesome hunk got a wacky snack
you don't just eat you dunk cookies are
no one saying flashes on the other the
creamy taste will drive you wild let's
have another dunkaroo soccer rules you
don't just eat the Google frosting line
Chuck chocolate vanilla yummy cookies
too tastes so good with a glass of moo
don't go roast
all right well should we try one yeah we
could have been rappers we're doing good
cheers
you know Duncan it's the whole thing of
it all right
look at that
main one's for alfalfa
not bad not bad
I mean it's
like Amanda had said it's totally right
it's not chocolate it's chocolate
frosting on a cake isn't it
it takes like chemicals to you I don't I
don't think I like it no I'll do another
one though I would have liked my
chocolate frosting to be a little bit
more that relatively iconic hazelnut
chocolate frosting that you find in
Europe which I won't mention because
they don't sponsor us do you know what I
mean Nutella oh you've said it ever they
need to give us cash for that I put that
in pancakes this morning
I love Nutella I'm eating Nutella
pancakes the next time you stay over
is Jack's favorite breakfast probably
so it's just simply
um pancakes and Nutella I make it's a
crepe
I make the I make it from scratch
and then uh I mean super thin put some
Nutella and then I fold it up like a
crepe and then I put uh put a powdered
sugar on top that's very sugary isn't it
right let's get back to the dunkaroos
I I do have a hard time with
eating food that immediately tastes of
chemicals to me and this is quite
chemically isn't it and is it mainly the
the the dunk and the dunkaroo let me
just try a cracker without
the crackers are not bad actually the
Cracker's all right though yeah I think
it's the chocolate filling isn't it I'm
going to try to adjust the chocolate now
right
see if we were in nine and a half weeks
and meet you lick out of my finger oh
I'd love that oh yeah
you gotta lick it all off that looks
like you've had an accident
what game times not a good one
hey there was a story of uh I was
chatting to the guys on the boat who
went scuba diving this week and they
said uh someone had accidentally
let's just say soiled themselves in the
wetsuit so they came out of the ocean
and a couple of the crew were like
that's a bit of a weird smell around
here and they went over to this guy who
they thought was struggling because he'd
swallowed a lot of seawater and one of
the guys said just pull the bottom of
your wetsuit where you where your ankles
are just to the side just to drain out a
bit of water and he drained out water
but it was
it was rusty water and they said I think
you've had an accident and the guy said
no no I've not had an accident he was
embarrassed and they're hosing down the
boat and the guy said look it's no
problem just jump in the water and take
your wetsuit off and wetsuit off in the
city it happens not a big deal but the
guy kind of denied that it was happening
so they got him to jump in the sea and
then they asked one of the dive
instructors to just go over and just
kind of get as much sea water in there
as possible and they said the ocean was
was brown with feces and they'd asked
the guys to uh put the snorkels in their
mouth and not not accidentally drink
from the surface of the water is that
that makes you poo doesn't it it's full
of uh
fecal matter anyway we shouldn't be
talking about fecal matter when we're
eating a chocolatey well just to finish
yeah okay a very quick story that uh
from our friend of Maine at school
Primary School yeah called Donald I said
I'd never tell this story but you've
named him as well yeah Donald and we've
already done we were walking back from
lunch one day from my Grant's house and
he he stopped during the walk and he
went like that was his chose your leg is
panic and like that
and a little poo feeling
how long they've been keeping that in
there and now I just looked at it and I
looked at Donald and Donald just said
don't tell anyone
we sail when you say a little poo what
do you think Could Happen do you think
he just thought
I'll just do it I'll just let one go
here and it was a solid it looked as if
he's maybe been constipated in any he
got some movement and it was quite a hit
it made a thud I'll tell you most well
I've I've actually got two stories but I
won't tell the big one because you know
the big one I'll tell you a small one
when I was a little kid I remember being
at the zoo
and thinking I don't want to go to the
toilet because there's orangutans and
gorillas and cheaters to see so I just
thought I'll just I'll just go to the
toilet in my trousers and I'll just hang
on to it and then I remember my mum
coming over to me a few times and saying
do you need to go to the toilet and I
was like no no I'm fine I'm fine she's
like come on you need to go to the
toilet I said no I'm fine and eventually
went to the toilet and disposed of um
what I'd been carrying around and I
distinctly remember it had like a
handprint in it what do you mean you
went and then you held on yeah I held so
I did it I did a uh and then I just held
on to it thinking oh you're held on hold
on to it thinking I don't embarrass
myself I've already embarrassed her I
don't embarrass myself here and have it
fall out the bottom of my trouser so
I'll just hold it and then when I
dispose of it into the toilet bowl
remember looking down and thinking I can
see the imprint of my of my hand in that
Joby so that's embarrassing so probably
if the police who came there with a
Dustin tool I could have probably known
that for sure
my fingerprints and it and there's
another
um awful uh story of defecation at work
involving me but I said that I wouldn't
um tell the story until we reached
a certain amount of uh followers or
subscribers should we say two hundred
thousand two hundred thousand okay let's
do that well hey see if you give me
I wouldn't swap you anything for it I
wouldn't I wouldn't swap you an old
cheesy sandwich I'd rather have a dairy
Lee dunker I would rather I mean pretty
much anything than a dunkaroo man and
not it's not great is it um should we
give it some scores yeah come on Dom
first and foremost flavor flavor
are we splitting it into two or are we
combining it combining up it's just one
thing a dunkaroo is one thing because I
agree I think the the cracker the
biscuit is all right but the chocolate
thing but it's a whole thing I'm sorry
Tom I can I can really own it
I can really only give it a three
yeah I've not liked it um
I'll give it a four yeah there's no
reason to use it how do you think it
looks dumb it looks alright actually I
like the the look of the the cookie is
quite nice it's like a tiny miniature
Rusk that you would give to a tiny
little baby right yeah that's crying
it's got a D on it which is like my name
Dom oh yeah in case you've forgotten
done where's the kangaroos yeah open one
that's got a kangaroo on it I don't
think well how because all the pictures
the little um basketball yeah well we
get this blurb from Johnny Clues don't
we and sometimes he just talks out of
this posterior no there's no kangaroos
in that one either the actual cookies
all right the Cookie's all right and
then the and then the chocolate is not
it's a little dark meat for chocolate I
want my chocolate a little bit more of a
Milky variety okay it looks more like
Marmite that to me right or tree cool so
in terms of the aesthetic
I'm gonna give it a four again yeah well
I like things that come in a little pack
and you do things I like being I like
having jobs
but again it's not great looking I'll
give it a five five and then usefulness
usefulness no would you would you take
these cookies break them down put it to
the topping of a pie that you've made
yeah you could do that with a cake would
you do it with this
chocolate thing I mean you you could
have that be the the middle part of the
cake it's not good is it taste like it's
not good flavor though I always think in
terms of usefulness can you take this to
the um to a football game and pass it
out to the team you absolutely could
everyone gets a little I don't know what
it is
um you can take it on a trip you know
it's it is is literally to travel around
with
um I like the cookie yeah the Cookie's
quite nice I mean in terms of usefulness
I think it is quite useful but not
incredibly useful I'm gonna give it a
solid seven oh dumb useful what would I
ever do with it no three
I'll tell you something slightly
concerning here that it says on the box
contains
bio-engineered food ingredients I've
never read that on food before I've
never read that either that's crazy so
this was made by robots is that right
yeah food that isn't food it's made in
space is that the idea is bioengineered
food ingredients also lend more you can
learn more by going on to that website
there right well this has been brilliant
Daniel oh wait we need to give it some
scores oh yes yeah what we've got it's
good this is billion dollars my request
yeah here's my request I want you to
rate it in arbitrary measures and I'll
give you an example are you ready yeah
so I would give bricklotti
uh 14 out of 19 flannel shirts oh right
okay and and I would rate abelore
134 out of 200 Audis
we can do that we break our scores up
into uh we normally do but I mean we can
still do it we could just we could just
give them scores so for taste so we do
taste right Aesthetics any usefulness
not for all three though well just a
taste for this one
we'll do Aesthetics for this one oh gosh
three more drinks usefulness no we just
remember okay taste for this one Dom but
marked in the way that Daniel would like
Chase for Brooke laddy it was good but
I'm not I wasn't feeling it as much as I
below I'm gonna give it a
I'm gonna give it a
6.2 out of ten
Lamborghini countaches well Lamborghini
wow all right wow for me
I would give that 24
out of 28
for Edinburgh streets oh that's good
yeah if you liked it yeah well it was
like an Edinburgh Street drink for me
love that hello you graded it at a
certain level but your category choice
is already elevated
Aesthetics the bottle how much looks
we're doing here this is how it looks
done how it looks it's a beautiful the
bottle the color how it sits in the
glass
and that's beautiful look at that look
at that label I'm gonna give I mean it's
a that's a lovely bottle of whiskey I'm
going to give that a
8.8
out of
10 Persian cats
ah that's a guess
lovely I'll give that
because that's lovely though it is it
might be the best one I feel the whiskey
just touching me now oh I'll give that
26 out of 28 again
out of 30.
sun rises
hold on
and when you're done you're gonna have
to show us where on the whiskey bottle
the whiskey touched you oh yeah sunrises
and Lewis
was that in Scotland oh it's on the west
coast there it's beautiful you can surf
there dumb oh I mean just finishing a
bottle of that as the sun comes up what
could be nicer me and you John I love it
get where wetsuits on and then we go
love it and then finally our final
category is usefulness we do usefulness
how useful is this in your life how
useful is this 12 year old bottle of
Apple so is that a fragment is that a
pragmatic what kind of you you can make
your own decisions there really okay
well wait a minute we never got we've
never got Daniel's aesthetic how does
the abber lure this abalore look to you
we forgotten man I'm gonna rate that
pretty damn high as well yeah it looks
like uh
uh
I'm gonna rate it 13 out of 15 mirsham
pipes
awesome yeah that's awesome I'd see
sitting in the weather there
now usefulness obviously after a long
stressful day's Works nice to have a
little glass of whiskey just could you
could you put it in anything could you
could you add it to like a shortbread
and give it a little whiskey Tang I
don't know could you I don't know could
you you could definitely put it in a
little uh hip flask and take it into a
concert with you no save you some money
um that's an expensive warms you up but
it definitely it warms you up by the
fire mm-hmm I mean it does what whiskey
does I mean if you're sitting in your
house and you said oh and I need to eat
something this isn't going to help much
it's not the most versatile of things
you've ever done but it does like I said
it does the job that it's supposed to
I'm gonna give it
four
out of nine ring rates
that's fair yeah well I'm gonna say well
Daniel did see it it opens you up to
conversation yeah
and and just just enjoying each other's
company yeah so I'll give that
9 or a ten
wow friends around the fire
ah damn it come on Daniel give us a time
how useful is it to you
so I value something that is beautiful
because it's not practical ah see right
and this is not practical if if you just
for practical purposes I can get you a
20 bourbon right so if we're going I'm
gonna approach this totally opposite
for the raw pragmatism right okay I'm
gonna give this three out of ten
uh dually pickup trucks oh my God good
we'll go mild medium hot so it's Johnny
Yes the the rear one will be the mild
the real one
Anaheim hot sauce okay so Michael we're
going to start with Anaheim okay okay
[Music]
you put a little bit over your thumb
there Mike I don't know if that was it
don't worry about that
too that thumb's been part of some
amazing cards over the years actually
that's really good right I'm right off
the thumb it's great yes yes I like
spice and I must say if this is the
mildest there's a little bit of a kick
there's a nice kick to that that's the
mild it's now what's in that one that's
Anaheim Peppers uh I believe I put like
onion whole garlic some uh spices
various spices maybe like parsley dried
spices and there's just a salted Brine
and then I fermented it for like three
and a half weeks I think really so that
tames the the spice level John you need
to calm down right hold on I just need
to calm down over there because you're
getting very excited are you having it
on its own yeah
so and Michael we saw we saw these
things based on three different
categories flavor
the the aesthetic and usefulness which
was a billy uh category so aesthetic
meaning the color the look The okay the
vibe so flavor
uh I'm gonna give mine a six out of ten
I'll give that a seven out of ten yeah
I'll give it a like I'll go seven out of
ten okay Aesthetics it's a nice color
I'm gonna give it an eight out of ten
yeah it looks as if like blood has been
uh mixed with piss I'm giving a high
score
it gets an eleven yeah that's a good one
and then usefulness I mean it's a hot
sauce do you know what I mean actually
that'd be great on scrambled eggs oh
absolutely yeah you can put it into all
sorts of cooking you can take it with
you to a cafe I'm giving it an eight and
a half out of ten then sure am I though
right this is the slightly hotter one
what do we got here I'll give you it's a
little it's so that will be the hardest
One Stop you Johnny I'm gonna stop
useful as oh and how useful it's innate
for me because yeah it's great I'll put
it on anything right this is the this is
the medium one that's the meme that's my
focus is
I wouldn't say it's medium it's probably
like a medium it's like a hot medium
Buffalo Wild Wings
deciding like the hot scale do you
actually oh well because the raw
habanero is like obviously very hot
because it's habanero but the mango kind
of teams it by you know putting in like
half a mango into that but it's a little
bit more fruity which complements the
habanero which kind of has a fruitiness
to it Buffalo Wild Wings which I should
not be advertising on the show but I'm
gonna do it anyway they do a whole slew
of flavors with their wings and they do
a cauliflowering if you're a vegetarian
and my favorite flavor that they do is
mango habanero John really see how it
adds up here you go Michael you got you
kick that off all right oh I'm exhausted
right here all right here we go nobody
panic
it's a sneaker
it's a sneaker it's a sneaker is it okay
let's see put a little bit on there come
on squirt your sauce on my veggies
here we go Johnny okay
I'm sorry if I'm gonna have it just on a
on a chip
what oh I like it
are you all right it is magnificent I
love that that's amazing
that's medium I got the hot ones really
gonna give us a talking to
I want to find ghost peppers because
that's like my dream now now do you grow
them any of these yourself you can grow
these yourself have are these yeah I'm a
horrible Gardener but Dom maybe don
should grow some ghost peppers yeah the
uh my girlfriend Andrea she had this
incredible
Garden through covet she just went
Garden crazy and she made this massive
garden with uh tomatoes and all kinds of
peppers and all kinds of I mean it was
incredible so in the morning I just go
grab a bunch chop them up throw them in
the eggs and it was oh yeah now she
doesn't want to continue doing it
because it's so much work yeah it's a
lot of work so it's you know so maybe
something I try growing a few things all
of them died unfortunately
right now let's score it so flavor ask
that flavor Aesthetics and usefulness
flavor I prefer that one to the mild one
I'm giving that John a 9 out of ten I'm
enjoying it it's a good it's a it's a
sword night yeah Michael absolutely
across the board yeah wow wow I prefer
that look to the medium one it's it's
got a kind of a tangerine type one is
that yeah this one the one that's
slightly open yeah I'm gonna give it
I'm going to give it an 8.5 for the for
them and it'll sneak up on you because
that doesn't look hot no no yeah I'm
gonna give this look a 10 because when
you when you when you brought it when
you brought it into the room I looked at
that one I was like that's the one I
want to try because I don't know it
looks like it has a creaminess to it yes
yeah it looks that's great really yeah
I'll get a 9.2 it's a high job
that is the one I use mostly at home oh
it is you can obviously tell because the
Anaheim one has nothing missing so what
listen what's the name of this one again
that one's just mango habanero but you
add the mangoes after it's not Adam
during the ferment I would probably give
the name like a five yeah you need to
work on the name John so I think it
needs something more maybe I'll name
them after your movies
The Inside Out sucks
sorry about that guys if there's any
families listed
usefulness well it's the same as any
other hot sauce you put it in your
scrambled eggs you put it in your rice
dishes yeah I'm giving it enough maybe
even more because it's got that on my
sandwiches I'm gonna go nine out of ten
this is guys right so now this is the
last one John is that yeah that one's
probably my second favorite but it's
gonna be a little bit hotter because
there's nothing to cut it do you think
you should be telling us which is your
first favorite and second favorite I
don't know I feel like you're oh now
what's the name of this one John that's
just uh you know another really unique
name it's just called Habanero hot sauce
so this is no mango no mango that's what
you could call it no mango Michael no
mango thank you I'm just gonna try this
simply on a chip
foreign
let's see just maybe give your T-shirt a
dusting down because you're covered in
crumbs like an old man that's lost his
mind someone that's dandruff is it yeah
some hairs just a little the bigger
pieces it's Bob's hair yeah some of that
are pure Bob lovely right hey Johnny
that's nice I know I've just touched my
nose and my nose don't touch your eyes
yeah no don't touch your eyes that's
really good
John I enjoyed that yeah yeah that feels
like a very good like um everyday
hot sauce that was that's why half of
it's missing some more of the mango one
on my taco to finish yeah
we did the final one some score yeah
the mango one last we should see it was
the best yeah because it's that's
disappointed me now I'm sorry that Thug
sauce was yeah a distinct disappointment
yeah well there you go you could call it
distinct disappointment sauce that's a
good name for it again good name again
remember we were talking about sadness
yeah it feels in a wave of sadness yeah
definitely enough Anarchy
no it was actually really good
let's score it in that case Billy you
kick it off start on the low end no I is
still very good and if it was the First
Source there would have been a high
score no it's the last song Right six
out of ten six out of ten yeah it's not
as good as the mango one for me I'm
gonna give it a 7.5 I was just gonna say
7.5 yeah
no Dom how does it look to you which one
is it again this one it's the one
closest to this one that one so all
right well it's sort of in between these
two words it feels like yeah so it's
just it's a seven yeah seven in terms of
looks I'll give it a neat I think it
looks nice yeah is it useful I go I
guess I'd go seven and a half seven and
a half is it useful I mean is it any
more useful than the mango one I don't
think so I think the only use it has is
to see that the mango one is better yeah
yeah yeah so that's basically yes how
useful it is you put it against the
mango one and you see it's not as good
it's the reason the number two was
invented exactly yeah okay yeah okay
there we go okay I'll give it for
usefulness we'll give
I'll get it I'll be slightly more
charitable I'll give it a 5.5 thank
six I mean you know yeah I'll give it a
six drawing a success
Billy and dumb eat the worlds ever and
my mouth is in fire sneakers it's gonna
be like it's the best give it a few
minutes and you're gonna be like
Okay so we've got a California
I can't say that no coloring Caroline
which is weird because my cousins I
think we're I think we're getting pushed
a little bit for time there so I didn't
know for if we're doing the uh sauces
and all that we'll just take a now what
would you you said you're not supposed
to eat is on their own so should we just
take a tiny bite Ed is that the idea
well you it depends on how daring you
are uh I truly you know I love you guys
I'll send you whatever sauce you want to
your house but if you eat that old
pepper I'm gonna be taking over
okay so we'll just take a bite you ready
let's do it you're okay then I just want
to see how much of a bite you take I'm
going to see that end but yeah I'm going
to take that right off all right I'll do
the same hang on
right let's talk through it right so
actually starts like a bell pepper like
a yeah it has really sweet flavor it's
uh the simple sugars I was Raising those
because my my thought behind it was that
chemo patients can taste simple sugars
it's the complex carbs that uh really
make them sick so if I raise the
sweetness uh maybe they would eat more
food and not starve to death I agree
there's some sweetness there's a little
heat coming through
a little but nothing that's scaring me
yeah now to the extent that I'm going to
take another little bite really yeah
awesome what part of my body gets the
heat is a great question right question
well uh your whole body has those
receptors right okay but what happens
normally is the oil gets stuck in your
taste buds in your tongue your your
taste buds kind of look like trees right
and the oil from the pepper gets under
that taste bud and then the chemical
reaction just starts rolling and it
can't escape right so most people
perceive it on their tongue first and
then in their throat uh but then they
make the mistake of wiping their eyes or
you know
something go near the top is the top
section though yeah you guys see what my
wife calls the cheater piece it gives
you the flavor without it because the
flavors actually really nice yeah the
flavor is still lovely Ed but I'm now
getting box oh yeah
yeah you get it
I took quite a lot I think you've not
taken anywhere near as well let me see
it I'll take more there I took I took
that that section that cross section
there yeah
brilliant you guys obviously are
professionals because most people die if
you if you look at other interviews with
me I I have to take over no look we love
we love hot spicy food Billy and I have
a lot of very common interests and I
think one of them is exploring new types
of food and if it can be spicy we're
absolutely over the moon about it it is
consistently getting hotter yeah
yes yes no all the hot hiccups oh yeah
so it's it's crazy isn't it the the the
sensation of heat so there is nothing
that is heating up on our tongue you're
right bills nothing in our mouth is
actually getting hotter
reaction you perceive as he you know uh
like my favorite things with the reaper
are uh Indian food it pairs so well with
Indian food
vindaloo yeah yeah is amazing yeah yeah
vindaloo is incredible Oh Billy you're
really feeling that one
are you getting hot lips I know it's
like my whole
have a little bit of water maybe I'm
gonna you're gonna no don't don't drink
water it's just gonna make it worse oh
well Ed here's a question because I've
been desperately trying to get on that
show hot ones hopefully with Billy at
some point and at this point it's just
way too easy for you to eat something
else that's definitely spicy at this
point we've not we've not been able to
go on the show but
what would you say if you eat something
hot and you want to cool it down should
you drink milk should you should you eat
ice what should you eat what should you
do well see every time I watch people
chug milk to get rid of heat they think
the fat is going to break up the oils
and stuff they wind up drinking a half
gallon of milk and then they throw up
and say oh that's damn Pepper made me
throw up it's not the pepper you're not
supposed to drink a half gallon of milk
at once
disperse the oil me personally I use
citric acid okay like grapefruit juice
or lime juice or lemon juice citric acid
yeah it slows it down so it doesn't make
it go away from the reaction don't say
we have citric acid but um so in an
ideal world you would what squeeze a
lemon and then you drink like pure lemon
juice
yeah or I I just take a piece of lime
and start chewing on it or whatever but
really it's all a matter of time okay
not people it takes 10 minutes some
people it takes 20. you know I feel like
I can feel a pulse and back in my head
now I love this this is my favorite show
ever like my head is like like I feel as
if my headphones are going like this
yeah yes kind of like you did some
nitrous oxide or something but I tell
you what Ed you had mentioned earlier on
about the Euphoria the High I mean I've
got my whole mouth and my lips are on
fire but my brain feels like it's kind
of zipping a little faster than normal
maybe maybe it's because my mate Billy's
almost about to pass out it could be
that I mean it's definitely
I mean it's it's hot to the point that
it's doing something to my body that no
other uh papers never done you know I've
never felt that policy incredible you
know I've had hot things with like
Indian food where my nose runs but
yeah that's a different feeling I was
just saying through the window there Dom
I think there's somebody else in the
studio who should try it out well not
only is Johnny Clues made his own hot
sauces well he's he's a master he's a
hot sauce Aficionado now John as as you
might have seen Billy and I started with
the little tip I think you should start
with the tip because that'll give you
the pepper flavor you get the flavor
then so yeah and it's a lovely and then
take a little bite from the top area
I'm not a little nervous it's like no
and it's not it's not something that you
can't handle but no try the tip so you
get that kind of almost kind of red
pepper bell pepper taste we'll give it a
score well well you're um my hands are
shaking yeah you're okay Billy there
really had a moment he had a moment all
right so I'm gonna do this little tip
now that just tastes like a pepper
really it's kind of sweet maybe a little
bit of heat but not really right
um see the flavor though it's nice
it's like a red pepper and then if you
go closer to where then you have to go
down to where the stem is
then you then you'll immediately be like
oh okay it's almost like a completely
different thing I'm sorry in the sign
yeah there's a loan take the side though
we've already oh my God
he said he's worried them my sand is
shaking it's not that bad
[Laughter]
right that's good was that a good chunk
is that a good oh yeah but your glasses
just steamed up it's hot and my ears
were sweating I took off my headphones
and my ears were sweating
yeah it's hot isn't it John
yeah so we'll land right in your uh
-huh
yeah but there is like a fruitiness oh
yes a little sweetness coming through
and then it goes hot in different places
my teeth started getting hot at one
point
oh my gosh yeah this feels like well
Billy while John deals with that for a
second should we give it scores yeah
well for the flavor that little top part
that's a delicious pepper flavor and I
have to give that a 9.3 wow for the hot
crazy hotness yeah not for the actual
flavor the flavor The Taste yeah
I'm gonna say I mean it was hot I'm good
but I loved it too uh I'll give it an
8.2
give her a score for flavor flavor it
was a lot nine point the bottom part
I'll give that a little tip I'll give
that
add a little bit lovely flavor 8.9 hello
80. 8.9 yeah
that's the heat part yeah yeah oh yeah
you've got water there if you need it
John don't worry you've got milk
foreign
I quite like it it's a it's a cute
little uh cheeky orange number and it's
got a strange little tip on it it looks
like a devil's hat good look love that
color I love it uh I'm like a dehydrated
pepper I'm gonna give it a
an eight it's a good score
um how I like the look of it as well
done I'm having another bite go on yeah
are you really I'll give it an 8.2 damn
how did you sit here the whole time just
like
it's hot but I like to really be in the
thicker things and just see how I can
I'm sweating look I can see on screen
I'm sweating John's sweating his eyes
are sweating yeah don't just be careful
about touching your eyes yeah don't
touch your eyes if you
um Billy did you give it score for the
look I did John what about the look look
I might go 9.8 well it makes it look
yeah he's loving it because it looks
kind of friendly yeah how useful is it
well you've got your hot sauces you've
got all your medical significance my God
that's incredible
I mean and food wise
I mean Ed was saying it's the most
popular thing that people have on the
table now not not ketchup or mustard or
mayo and it's gone around the world
Peppers that pepper taste has gone
around the world and if you put it in a
food processor as he said some vinegar a
little bit garlic onions in you want you
make your own sauce as our friend uh
Johnny Clues tells us John looks like
he's been kicked in the balls have you
John it is an experience
to speak yeah he's crying uh usefulness
I I can't give it a perfect 10 but I'm
gonna give it pretty close I'm gonna
give it a 9.7 I'm gonna get as a
usefulness
I'm gonna give it a 9.9 wow I mean it's
incredibly useful isn't it John that's
very useful that is um
well as it feels like my stomach's
sweating yeah it's hot I feel it like
right in there right uh uh would you ask
me how beautiful is it useful I mean
this would be a fun like hey how about
you you try this
you know like did somebody
at a party yeah you know hey yeah
wow it's hot news
on your poor angel don't touch your eyes
whatever you do for us yeah it's like
it's the stomach I feel like uh
like the endorphins you're right right
it is this like throbby yeah well Billy
Billy had hot hiccups and I've never
seen you have hot hiccups no that's some
people eat the whole thing what people
just I've seen videos yeah that's strong
crazy I feel like we should all finish
the episode by doing that are you gonna
be able to eat anything I'm going to do
it you I mean you should be happy
because mine's pretty bland will you
thank me do you would you like a ghost
pepper with yours
no you're doing that you don't have to
Tiffany
I'll do it I will why not all right
great just a bag we'll show you how much
I'm not gonna eat the seed though no
don't you sure you might do that William
don't talk around an experience well I
wouldn't dumb what are you gonna do with
this pepper because do you think we're
gonna do no I'm gonna taste a piece of
them after everything I'm not doing it
now we still have some of these what was
it called dumb Carolina Reaper but I I
unfortunately called it the calorina
reaper he's going to get it out for a
few times you could almost not get there
the Carolina Reaper it was good the
great thing I would say about it is it
is hot and spicy but the feeling lasts
for about 10 minutes you'll you'll
notice if you eat it down in the seat
which I did I don't think he did this
conversation
don't worry unless you want it really
intense I could have eaten the seeds and
run a mile John ate the seeds and he had
to run to the nearest toilet we're
having a potato which is my father's
favorite meal hello Dad why a potato I'm
like not the biggest Foodie in the world
but a baked potato with cheddar cheese
and bacon and butter and sour cream is
like the most comfort food of comfort
foods for me I'm gonna I'm gonna taste
it it was making by Johnny clue yeah do
you remember it was was potatoes a big
thing in your family
I thought you're about to look in the
bio if it's anything about potatoes
[Laughter]
um I don't like no
I was really picky when I was I'm trying
to think because I don't remember a lot
of stuff from when I was younger but I
think it's because they're all such good
memories so it's like everything kind of
Blends together so sometimes I'm like
did I do that did I like this the
Whirlwind yeah like I know I liked pasta
with just a lot of butter and cheese now
Tiffany you will
in a perfect world have a baked potato
with cheese bacon and butter is that
your all-time favorite way to have a
baby yeah with sour cream and ranch
dressing on the side oh wow we do have
it done
um I think butter salt and pepper
I like I like it hot I put some hot
sauce in there maybe a little cayenne
pepper a little turmeric something like
that what about you bills I'd have it
with tuna fish
mayonnaise
and a a finely sliced onion see again
you're doing the thing where you're
looking right at me and I'm like
it's true it's a tuna casserole
tuna mayonnaise yeah and then it's my
wife who says you should cut up an onion
I love raw red onions
now he said hot pepper Tiffany wait what
about sweet corn no sweet corn in that
paper too that's a great combination
with tuna and mayonnaise I know you mean
John but I just I'm trying to make it
easy for myself and I don't know if I've
got sweet corn
if I'm bulking
should we move on no we get the scores
but before we score it do you really
want to taste that I do actually I think
you should I think because I'm saying
you shouldn't I'm doing it well like how
much I I need to know like how much like
we did like did you eat this whole thing
no no no like this little nuts no no no
no see that's two different hold on I'll
point out with these glasses with the
legs of your glasses Billy so see this
top bit it's got no heat it's like a
bell pepper you get a tears from there
but see that little bit that looks like
a little swirly doodad like that beat
that I'd have something maybe the size
of a half a penny or a quarter of a
penny something like that but try try
the little spiky bit because they'll be
it'll just be like a bell pepper
initially there'll be nothing that
you'll think oh that's hot it's just
like a bell pepper right
foreign
you'll be okay with that I think
it was a throwing a bit off you never
even took it come on just like like the
like a quarter of a penny come on I
can't I can't eat a quarter of a penny
my mouth is already
an eighth of a penny I took it down the
receipt Stone didn't even know if you
did get to the Seas you know oh no
that's too much
don't touch it don't touch your eyes
yeah don't touch your eyes now talk us
through your symptoms
um heat to hot heat so first my tongue
was really hot now my whole throat is
really um right don't touch it I know I
know don't don't use that because that's
been on there I actually got hot teeth
hot teeth and hot dogs yeah I got the
hiccups happening it's just really hot
it's hot isn't it fine no you're doing
okay great we're going to give scores to
the baked potatoes okay
the first thing we do
the first thing we do the potato will
help yeah
ill nullify
women didn't he said don't eat up any
root vegetable he said I always activate
it okay what can I have a tissue for My
Eyes Crying oh okay don't touch it you
touched it what happened with this thing
use the other one now use the bottom one
you're fine
Tiffany yeah what's it feel like
oh yeah you're like your cute little
face is perspiring it feels like I got
something in my eye like yeah touch your
eyes whatever you do no flavor baked
potatoes there's no flavor no no no
potato that's the first thing that we
score and also just so you know one of
the first symptoms of eating the hot
pepper is absolute Madness and it does
seem like you're moving into that Arena
all crying yeah Billy let's you and I do
a flavor thing and give Tiffany a moment
just to collect herself the flavor of a
baked potato especially when made by
Johnny Cruz is up there as one of the
greatest flavors available to the human
can I disagree why well I would say a
baked potato that doesn't include any of
the gobbins the effects like same
chicken soup is just what
yeah so we're including the stuff that
you add into it yeah is that what we're
saying yeah in that case yeah it's quite
good
potatoes are really good but potatoes
are good they're like the best thing in
the world
potatoes are good I just found them in a
little boring but yeah if you had some
fixings and I did add some hot sauce all
right I'm giving it a six out of ten I'm
giving a 9.1 wow I like it I love the
flavor Tiffany
about that potato experience crying
because of how much you don't like
potatoes I'm sorry I like it Mom do you
want to score it as well I mean
yeah I mean in general the score of
baked potatoes I would say a 10 out of
ten oh wait 10 out of 10 out of 10. this
baked potato I like the cheese to be
really melty
God's sake man we're gonna dump it a
point nine and nine minutes
he went and got up he went out and got
all the stuff and he made the bacon
crispy which is like 0.1 of a decimal
point they were made three hours ago
sweet Jesus how are you feeling now what
do you guys running wait till you get
the stomach crumbs I'm not gonna get the
stomach cramps
that's because I went down to received
snobdales went down
really uh
the Aesthetics of a baked potato which
to be fair I would say looks like a
rhino [ __ ] well
what I like to do but it's not when it's
not like yeah yeah I got it I cut it and
then I'll open it like a flower remember
those toys used to get when you were
younger one two three four five six
color blue what b u e
number no beer pick a number three one
two three right pick one of them right
who is this or who uh who I'm gonna
marry yeah you love Jane ah who's Jane
are you still married to Allison who is
Jay I'm not saying you genus sorry
Allison holy moly oh you're okay
I keep thinking I'm okay and then my
mouth is like no you're not wait dude no
I'm afraid to breathe in I think it will
make it hotter no yeah just breathe out
wait till the crumbs come did you go
downstairs I'm the only one who went
down
yeah
the the look The Aesthetics of a baked
potato with the fixings or without the
fixings I see we've got to go with
though
cheddar cheese
Salt and Pepper please sure come for
that
a Philistine
uh I mean it's a nice look it's a nice
look I don't eat bacon but it's a nice
look I'm gonna give it an eight yeah I
like it I'm going to give it an 8.4
you think it looks Less Pleasant than it
tastes yeah
um I mean it's not like you know if you
went a Japanese restaurant
you like like okay you like presentation
food well I'm just saying if it's like a
baby bite I'm like no but I'm hungry I'm
sitting down because I want a meal what
about a king bye do you ever create a
king bite for yourself what's that a
king bite is like you have created what
you consider to be the Best Buy in your
meal where you're like I've tried this
sauce I've tried this side thing I know
it's happened to you guys where it's
like randomly all of your saliva and
then you swallow it and your saliva is
really hot yeah have you got a post map
back in my neck just like right here
it's just like all in my mouth my thing
is because I took it down to the seeds I
don't think you did it did you eat the
seeds yeah
my ears were sweating
yeah it takes a lot it's like an
elephant then
um
uh wait we were talking about potatoes
presentations
yeah the way the other KingBach is
you've tried all the things right and
you're like right I don't want too much
the gravy because it's okay but it's not
great so you create a king bite and then
you have that when you're at your most
hungry so I do like a weird thing
because I think
I used to everything always had to be
separated for me when I was little um
so I can't decide sometimes if I want to
have the best bite first when I'm hungry
to enjoy it yeah or save it to the end
but then I'm full so I don't enjoy it as
much I think you have a star my friends
used to about me and my friend Tom used
to always threaten it never happened to
go to McDonald's and eat the whole menu
never happened yeah I could have done it
but Tom always claimed that he could do
it and I always used to debate with him
I was like well what would we have first
and he was like get the rubbish out of
the way yeah have the hamburger the
cheeseburger the nuggets and I was like
no no have the best thing first because
you want to celebrate the meal and then
you just sluggishly get through and then
at the end you won't enjoy it never
happened before you won't enjoy it
anyway I've given my score for the
Aesthetics right we all have oh so now
I'll give it in I gave it a 9.9 yeah 9.9
because yeah usefulness Billy this is a
category that Billy ten
talk us through the different ways that
it can be useful oh usefulness for my
body or like potatoes you want to talk
about your body that's fine but let's do
it if a light bulb breaks you can use a
potato no no there's no light coming out
of a potato I've tried it I've turned
off all the lights at night screw it if
your light bulb breaks you shove the
potato onto it and you unscrew it that
might be extremely enough if you plug a
light bulb in your potato it will later
up because it works as a battery yeah
there's some electricity
you can make french fries you can make
hash browns from a baked potato uh but
we're just talking that's a potato we're
talking about you're taking it back so
usefulness
baked potato
if you're in the house
um and there's a baked potato maybe from
the day before and you're like oh I've
got guests coming over I've got baked
potato I've got three eggs I've got a
quarter milk an orange orange I've got
ice cube what can I do ice cubes do I
have my telephone
people downstairs to give you a bagel
you've got to make something from that
is it useful can I do something
versatile
I mean I could probably make some kind
of a like shepherd's pie something or
other
or hash browns Masha up put anything
made with nice oil yeah make it crispy
yeah send them pretty useful to me don't
swim also a lot yeah always goes loose
for you that much I know maybe if you're
struggling because you move it around a
lot oh do you yeah so usefulness
usefulness I'm gonna have to I'm giving
it a high one I'm giving a
8.7
I was good I've been swayed by the two
of you because initially I was like well
it's just a baked potato there's not a
lot going on there but I actually think
you guys are persuaded me so I'm gonna
go high then I thought
8.3 well that's quite High actually I
mean
potatoes getting up there Naomi says hey
my question would be if you could create
your own restaurant
what kind of food would you sell and
what would the aesthetic be
I actually have an idea for a restaurant
but I don't know if I want to give it
away on here because in case someone
does it
um I could think of another one yeah but
and then would you tell me the other one
at some point
no not you because you're a very honest
man do you want to hear my restaurant
yeah go on
um I would I would do a Scottish
restaurant all right because I like you
know just some simple Scottish things
you know I love to make uh potato scones
do you love a potato scones so we hear
this dog I'd caught why I'd call it the
second breakfast right or lovely and
then because that's a that's a that's a
callback to Lord of the Rings you see
and then I would you could you get all
sorts of breakfast in there but mainly
second second breakfast but potato
scones which as you know is mashed
potatoes and flour cooked in butter but
you do them wonderfully it's absent
about that they are ABS they're
triangles you see and uh it doesn't
matter what kind of triangle it can be
um isosceles isosceles it could be
equilateral yeah I mean there doesn't
have to be a hypotenuse could you do a
pentahedron no okay it has to be a
triangle and uh I would serve that with
eggs oh I like an egg beans are they
baked yeah thank good mushrooms oh yeah
fried potatoes oh now you're talking no
if you want a shortage with that yeah I
have turkey I've got pork or I have a
veggie I'd have a veggie sausage I'm
sorry we're sold out this morning okay
all right well I can add the turkey well
we'll sort out that as well we'll cancel
the sausage I'm fine yeah famous food
this was you know what you've ruined it
I'm going next door you can go next door
that's just as a shop that frames it's a
framing shop yeah all right in that case
I'll just have a slice of toast
oh God just a cup of coffee
nightmare what's this place called
second breakfast I'm gonna make a
complaint let me speak to the manager
hey I'm the manager get out okay I will
and then I've got a picture for him
anyway terrible restaurant I'll see you
next door all right
you've found a packet of chips that were
half open yeah so you guys have a bucket
you guys have a bucket of garbage over
there yeah half of the stuff is edible
first of all there's like a light bulb
in there yeah and I found and it was all
stuff that I've had before and one thing
that was weird like there were like blue
potato chips uh or blue flavored
potatoes yeah they were flavored blue
yeah and then I found these These are
ruffled uh all dressed potato chips so
what does all dress mean or every flavor
you can I think I'm fairly sure that
it's kind of brilliant in a way they
just take the leftover dust from all
their other chips and they put it on
this chip and you can only really get
them in Canada they're a big Canadian
thing right
um and I remember for some reason seeing
them a lot in New Orleans
uh
and uh and you guys happen to have some
now of course this bag
it's half open it's it's uh
we settled on the bag and then we
noticed that the it's you know white
it's been one the the bottom of the bag
has been taped up yeah and almost looks
like surgical tape or something
we open it up and let's have a look
inside
I think it's a worry that you're worried
I will be honest
and that as as sound and worse than the
tripe it's all flavors dust that's left
oh and someone's already opened it Rob's
a fan oh it's beautiful no they're
they're the best they're the best we
don't have a plate already
they're grape okay are you sure yeah 100
okay should we get little plates so we
can have a few here comes John no you're
gonna I don't know what the hesitation
is it's it's do you like flavored chips
but I don't like the idea that it's like
an afterthought and I don't like the
idea someone's opened it you want there
to be more Focus yeah and and fresher I
want it fresh yeah you want to want
somebody else's fingers
well it adds to it hold on let's give it
a little taste it adds to the Dust
oh
now that's a Tangy chip quite good
actually bills got a lot of barbecue and
now a lot of barbecue I think you know
every chip uh
is a little different too sometimes you
can taste the sour cream well yeah maybe
the um cheddar and onion
uh the Tomato
Tomatoes well there's ketchup
it's complicated there's a lot of cats I
taste the ketchup a lot does it is it
only Ruffles that are allowed to do an
old dress I don't think so no I think
it's just a type of Chip like sour cream
and onion well they're nice I like these
chips
let's go on John this is quite
interesting oh okay
um it's a flavor of mixture of ketchup
barbecue sauce barbecue sauce salt and
vinegar
um it was originated in Canada this is
where it came from uh now funny enough
Syracuse New York potato chip maker
tyrells began selling all your all
dressed chips on their name Syracuse
style which is interesting because my
wife is from upstate New York and they
have uh uh everything
buffalo wings which is all the sauces
it's the best I know it sounds weird but
they mix all the sauces and then just
glob it all over these and it's my
favorite uh it's too short but that's
about as interesting as it gets I'm
sorry I'm still well it's all right
so okay so you totally coat it with the
tomato ketchup no cheddar and onion no
sour cream and onion in there no I think
salt and vinegar barbecue and the
barbecue for sure you've obviously got a
very complicated palette I've actually
really stuffed up right now so I just
tasted a hint
uh I only uh felt the half the power of
those chips but that's a good chip
they're actually great interest Ruffles
does a great job I mean I'll tell you
what we we always mark them we give them
scores we oh yeah yeah um
there's three categories flavor of
course
for number one okay then Aesthetics how
does it look three how how useful is it
okay good how useful is a food how
useful is that like what would you do
like if someone came in your house oh
God Billy and you you would enter your
your cupboard and they said I'm hungry
and all you had was a bag of these you
see now a bag of flour eggs
the same thing everywhere
but I'll catch up oh okay job chocolate
chips whatever I mean what would you do
uh yeah you know what I mean you'd open
them but I think it might be weird yeah
I think it's kind of low on everything
but the taste scale right Billy's not
giving one anything attention
hold on I can't think because that's an
interesting flavor that until when you
started listing them I found it even
more interesting I think yeah it was in
my mouth and you were saying tomato and
I could taste it barbecue I could taste
it so I'm very I could taste that so
it's an interesting thing so I'm gonna
give it I'm gonna give it a for flavor
I'm giving a name yeah nice yeah when
when this initially started you you were
quite dismissive and snobby about this
it was mainly because of the surgical
tape around the bottom I'm a bit worried
about that yeah I'm so worried about it
I Love Your Capacity to change yeah
um I liked it too I'll uh I'll give it
any because blow me away but it was good
I'd like it with maybe some wrench yeah
I I think you might put more flavor just
to chill out the flavor you know like
yeah I would I would probably give it an
eight as well maybe an eight uh I'll
give it an 8.1 just a little bit higher
than an eight because
um
yeah it's fantastic but it's still at
the end of the day uh or chip yeah so
it's still a chat it's just still a chip
and when he started listing off what
wasn't in the chair all the powder I
thought I was eating
I sort of tasted I I could um I could I
could see the seams in it you know I
could see the like oh you don't like I
don't know now that we know how the
sausage is made no
um it's kind of uh maybe it maybe it's
lost a little bit of its luster I
definitely don't want to know how they
were made no no definitely all that
powder all through somebody's sweeping
up off yeah we'll just throw that I'm
sure everything's above board and then
the machine that seals the bag is broken
just get some subjects
no it's the difference well category two
aesthetic aesthetic how does it look
well it looks like a chip yeah but Billy
is ruffled
but also I don't like I don't like the
shade I don't like the color like an
like piss orange I would call that sorry
it's not consistent either it's pretty
blotchy no it's very it's not no I can't
it's a it's a 3.5 it'd be under I like
the ruffle
um I'll give it a four yeah that's what
I was gonna say I was going to say four
as well and then Billy's favorite
category is my favorite what's that oh
yeah if I had like say I was making a
soup would I sprinkle this on it oh like
a little bit see I was making say a pie
or a shepherd's pie you could put in a
sandwich
lovely Mayo with all those flavors right
so that's that nice in this sandwich
what about could you could you smash it
up into a dust and then maybe coat some
chicken and fry that and now you've got
like foreign
if you think about it that way there's
not a uh
a lot you could do with it yeah even
what we mentioned is not it's not great
a shitload of things I think a sandwich
is a good shout yeah
I would use them as um I think they'd be
great to dip into uh tuna salad lovely
you know right yeah just trying to think
of a different way that's a that's about
it yeah it's not the most useful it's
like all the flavor it's got their
cheese onion yeah barbecue and then
you're put you're putting fish on there
as well oh yeah I like the way you're
thinking it's extreme you know the um
my dad used to eat uh chocolate ice
cream with potato chips plain potato
chips because it's a salty sweet thing
yeah I never got into it but these you
couldn't do that with no it's too too
that's too much already
that's a two for me a two I'll give it
up I'm a
4.848 yeah 4.8 yeah well I'm definitely
lower than a five and I I think lower
than a four I'm gonna give it I'm gonna
give it a three five
um
yeah
3.575
3.575 yeah that's that's not quite
and that sounds about right five eight
exactly three five eight it's yeah it's
almost so well
three different points if you round up
but um I like to do everything with
three decimal points me too
for you what you suggested today is a
classic American American
The Bolognese here it goes now Bolognese
is is from a region in Italy called
Bolognese is that where they think
bologna bologna Bologna Italy yeah I
think it's kind of central hey
should we give it some skills yeah we
always score it and uh I think John did
a really good job because it's not easy
we've completely finished our plates
making something ahead of time and it's
you know you want that fresh Don't You
Wanna oh yeah yeah this was great I'll
give you a little spoiler that is made
with uh Beyond me wow no real me in
there lovely very healthy was it also
made with love could you tell us John
was it made with Beyond love or just
life
in there yeah
um okay now are we are we scoring this
Bolognese or bolognese
engine I think it has to be this this
one don't you think okay okay sure taste
yeah we do we use three categories
okay first one this is uh ten Brent you
can use decimal points if you right I'll
show you how I would do it I'm gonna
give that John it was delicious guys
I like a bit more sauce
pasta was slightly too authentic for me
oh yeah quite uh
and it was a paper plate a paper plate
um and that's a disgrace I mean you you
left the restaurant because the plate
wasn't warm enough and John decides the
server on you know
a dead tree uh Dom
well you're not happy no I'm happy
because I liked it but
I'd like to Fresh from his cooker
seven point
five
that's quite critical was it well you're
known as the charitable scorer out of
the two of us and that was quite
critical well pasta can be difficult I'm
gonna say given the limitations of what
John had to deal with today
I didn't know we were taking that into
account I always do carry on I'm gonna
give I'm gonna give it a solid eight
well that's quite good so that's good
that's good yeah I uh when I had my
first bite I was gonna ask if it was
chicken
um it tastes like beef but now he said
it's beyond that makes so much sense
um I yeah I typically would do kind of a
looser sauce so that it's
a little more liquidy but tight notes
you're you're a podcast producer yeah
that was forced to make a dish of pasta
uh so I gotta be a little critical but
also give you the benefit of the doubt
lovely and um I do like the noodles
actually I prefer mine Al Dente like
this oh there you go it's got a it's got
a nice bite to the noodles the
springiness I like the the size of the
carrots sometimes carrots can be
overwhelming they can be yeah and then
your old dish tastes like carrot yeah
um
John I'm gonna give you I'm going to
give this a 7.3 lovely well that's
something that's all right John I'm from
an Italian mother jet Italian yeah one
it doesn't take any [ __ ] yeah
I I always enjoy
a little bit of fresh grated cheese
which we didn't have today and that's
okay I can't believe you left that edge
but it's okay now the second category
William is um Aesthetics how does it
look or how did it looks like sure when
you looked at it did you say that is
pleasing to the eye uh did you just
ignore Tom give us a score well this is
where I'm gonna slightly demote John
although I enjoy him as a human
I agree with you guys I'd like a little
bit more of a tomatoey uh Saucy thing
almost as if it's drowning a little bit
shout a shallow drown shallow sauce so
I'll give him a six
for Aesthetics out now as I said um a
plastic I mean paper plate straight away
no because you're quite high for Luton I
mean we're not in a picnic are we we're
not enough we're not Philistines and
then the the amount of pasta I got was
good but I'd like it to be
exactly in the center of the plate oh
God John are you taking notes and pailed
up slightly like a like a shallow
volcano right and the lava coming out
the top is maybe the cheese no like the
sauce
and then I just um I mean you're
sprinkling almost like after a volcano
has went off the the dust that says what
a fresh sprig of Basil or as you might
say basil basil Nutella but it felt as
if John had no it aesthetically didn't
care what it looked like you're angry
with John today is there something else
going on have you guys
like it was a dirty protest oh skill
score it then give him a critique
oh
okay I really can only give it a 6.2 oh
it's damning what did you what did you
say I'm pretty I'm picky when it comes
to presentation Johnson
when I was handed this plate of pasta I
felt like I was I was being handed a
plate of pasta at a family reunion by an
aunt who never really liked me yeah you
know it was like me angry yeah I was
like oh I got caught sneaking out to let
out fireworks with my friend last night
and my mom told my aunt and my aunt
doesn't like me for it because I'm
getting my cousin involved in my
Shenanigans but she still has but she
has to feed me at the Family Reunion
yeah so as she feeds me she hands me the
plate and when she takes away her hand
she forms a middle finger yeah it's very
subtle so that she can kind of played
off as if she didn't do that that's what
this plate of food felt like I can
understand me John I gotta be honest
I was going to but then I thought you
know maybe we can make up for it at some
point he was a boat
um I'd say presentation wise I'd I'd uh
it was on the plate I'll give you that
it will go it was on the plate although
it was a paper plate as I have a man she
didn't mention that yeah it's become a
bit of an owl but trust that
I'd I'd give it you know
of 4.5 oh gosh
five John you went sub five
I had to uh worry about presentations
how long have you been the producer of
the Friendship onion that's over a year
I would think isn't it at least and you
you didn't think presentation was uh you
had to worry about it whereas it's
always scored every week we score a
presentation John I didn't think the
plate was uh part of that that was just
the pasta just one single noodle you
would hold up and say yeah yeah I
thought your choice of noodle was good
though is that like a thick penne of
something
yeah so yeah I don't know if you guys
saw but when Brent gave that score I was
looking directly into John's eyes and he
smarted
I love you boy this is going to be a
great one because do you remember a
little while ago there a lovely
gentleman come on with the Carolina
Reaper oh yeah the hottest paper ever
made by human hand and uh Johnny close
the wonderful Johnny clothes
disappeared with some of them yeah he
nicked off he's created a hot sauce is
that right he's invented it I hear I'm
just raw dogging the hot sauce I'm gonna
just take a drink
foreign
hold on I'll put some on that one now I
feel it in and around my lips oh John
there's some garlic in there that's
fantastic
there's a very strong garlicky taste
which actually helps the heat right
are you feeling the heat oh yeah feel
feel feel feel feel
the heat where's that what movie is that
from
um The Martian yeah close Boogie Nights
I watched Boogie Nights last night
that's good that John
now what I really like about that
is it is spicy there's no way that you
could describe it is there anything
other than spicy but because the garlic
taste is so strong it helps a little bit
with how hot the heat is have you got is
this the same John this ones get mango
yeah the other one has Ming going in
well do a little Switcheroo yeah that's
hot and I'm not getting much mango I'm
just basically getting paint okay I
added half a mango to then I was like oh
this has to be too much but I think
those Carolina Reapers is that is the
mango one hotter would you say no I
would say I mean it's cut with mango so
it shouldn't be as hot but let's have a
little guzzle with this shaking doesn't
it
fantastic hot sauces I gotta say I tell
you what John has done a lot of good
things
uh he's done a lot of bad oh a lot of
bad but he's done a lot of good things
when it comes to food and his hot sauces
or maybe my favorite thing if you walked
into a store and they had you know a
little tiny run of those 10 of those
locally made you'd be like well
absolutely I'd pay
what is that too hot that's right that
Johnny
and you two can fight over their gifts
to you so you know I like I like the
hotter garlicky one but they're both
fantastic they're great
John I tell you what if it all goes to
[ __ ] and your reputation is dirt in this
town we will back you up and say fine he
can't work anymore but he does make
fantastic hot sauces Billy you're
getting hiccups
that's really hot
no I can't do that Don I drank that
drink it again I'll do it drink it I'm
going to put a mark right and another
mat
he's getting hot hiccups hang on yeah
the hot hiccups are here that was a hot
burp oh god oh
yeah
that's too much Johnny
clean your face oh God clean your face
as well you've got fairness I had a I
added habanero
es attentively titled the friendly tarot
narrow oh nice job friendly what
caranero not only not only does he make
good hot sauces but he has good titles
and I think a huge thing about the hot
sauce that you select is based around
the title
are you all right you look like you're
about to have uh is it called an episode
I think I would cut I'd call that one
the Flaming [ __ ]
foreign
debate but I think if you had of eaten
the seeds you would have very strongly
said look look at that place there where
I've clearly eaten a seed well I don't
think I need to because the seeds were
missing
but in that section where the seeds were
missing there was no evidence that seeds
had been in some way messed about with I
I looked like that that particular seed
section of the chili had been uh
untarnished so what you're saying is
that piece of the chili didn't grow
seeds yeah I I just don't think you did
eat the seeds so an Asian debate I'm
going to try the mango again because I
think I like that better hold on John
very tasty
do you know I think about John
I think
he's a giver
he likes to make people happy I like to
make things for people of course he does
because he's he's never happier I don't
think than when he gets we get something
he says I'm going to cook that I'm going
to make that he says
it does it doesn't get that kind of
passion about
creating Lord of the Rings quizzes no no
he cares nothing about that hot sauce
easier man I've got a hot throat now
yeah
that's very good John uh the mango for
me
is is it's it's got a lot of heat in it
but it's bearable I wouldn't say too
much heat that one over there that's
fine ask it too much heat fine for me
though because just keep in mind that I
drank both of them neat that's
overpowering no not for me I don't think
you did drink it I think you put your
tongue on the end of it you put your
tongue on the end yeah and he lifted up
I would never do that I'm an honest man
I think you did that I don't think you
did eat the seats the other week either
I did you did the seeds uh well should
we give it some scores are we scoring
our favorite out of the two because my
favorite's the hotter one your favorites
the milder one two to four all right
flavor and or taste for both of them I'm
gonna give mine a solid 8.7 for flavor
yeah I loved it the garlic the
overwhelming garlic tastes yummy
I really like the flavor of this mango
one keep in mind you did get hot hiccups
that was from that one
for the mango one because I like
As We Know
I like a hot sauce
to give you that heat that fun oh yeah
but not overpower the the food no I want
some flavor and uh it's got a flavor oh
it's got heat in the back of my oh yeah
my soft palate yeah
it's very good John very good I'm gonna
give that a 9.2 9.2 he's loved it
Aesthetics it's in a lovely hot sauce
bottle I mean it's it's the type of
color that you'd expect from a hot sauce
it's a kind of fiery orange to red
devilish
I'm giving it a nine that's what I'm
looking for in a color of a hot sauce I
think John could have you know in the
time that he had could easily have
designed a little sticker for them oh
look a little sticky yeah had it printed
at the place next to the uh second
Breakfast Cafe
[Music]
um
so I'm gonna have to do a couple of
points off of that not fair enough so
I'll get that a 6.8
usefulness now we've already gone over
the usefulness of a hot sauce
scrambled eggs pasta on a pizza in a
sandwich
dips if you've got a dip and you're like
ah this hummus is okay it needs
something a little bit of hot sauce stir
it in I think hot sauce is one of the
more versatile things out there it's
very useful then in fact we heard from
our fantastic hot sauce expert that hot
sauce is the most popular condiment on
the American table top which is amazing
well popular than ketchup more popular
than A1 Sauce wow we're not about to say
names so we just did yeah
um so in terms of Versatility I mean I
can't think of any way that I would give
it anything other than a 10 out of 10.
oh he's banged out another ten I think
that's three tens you've given over the
years no no not tens across the board no
no that one just got a 10 in the final
usefulness nothing has ever got a 10
from me no and it will nothing is
perfect for you is it no and I think
that is very very versatile kind of like
John yeah
has hot sauce is like his nature I got a
bit stuck up there now I'm gonna give
that
a nine point
nine
close to perfect but nothing is perfect
if you're in the house and you've made
something you thought that needs a bit
of heat now
just a
shadow of a flavor of a mango I know
what I would tell reach for the uh
Johnny hot sauce lovely
[Music]
baby you're my Pearl
[Music]